[Music]
for 24 years I was an investigator for
the IRS and the FBI I started off
working bank robbery cases I ended up in
Chicago and worked political corruption
cases and after I retired I started
investigating lost apple varieties in
the late 1800s apples were extremely
important to early settlers in
Washington they grew a variety of apples
most of those people decided to the
farming was too hard but all over
Eastern Washington those old orchards
survived to this day sometimes I'll just
drive country roads and I'll look out
and I can recognize an apple tree from
you know a couple hundred yards away
I wonder what's planted there it's very
possible it could be one of these lost
varieties of Apple just waiting to be
found
I draw on my experience as an
investigator mainly through the use of
records I'm searching for clues of of
where these lost varieties grew I looked
at plat maps I look through museum
records and things like that then I go
out just like in law enforcement I'm
looking for physical evidence and I've
got to take a look at those apples I
make a map and record the GPS
coordinates I bag them up and I mail
them off to Apple identification experts
I'm collecting these apples from the
only known Dickenson apple tree in the
United States these apples are
absolutely delicious off the tree
there's only about ten of us now that
I've ever tasted
the Dickenson in the last hundred years
I began searching for lost apple
varieties probably about eight nine
years ago something like that
people often ask me why do you look for
these apples and I tell them that I have
been concerned that if I don't look for
them no one else will and these
varieties could be lost forever
so far I found three lost varieties of
apples those varieties include the Nero
and then the Arkansas beauty and the
Dickinson so we're down to about 20
varieties that we're looking for right
now and it's just a matter of time
hopefully to find those
[Music]
in a city that loves its bikes there is
one man looking out for the rest one man
brave enough to bring bike thieves to
justice a man the city calls bike Batman
in reality I'm just an engineer back in
the early 2000s I started really
noticing you know there's a lot of bike
theft I read it said a wheel stolen I
was livid I was super poor and there was
nothing to do you know I couldn't
recover them it was so frustrating for
me knowing that the police are so busy
with so many other crimes in Seattle
that there was nobody following up on
these minor incidents enough was enough
he realized he needed to take the law
into his own hands and he had the
perfect plan
I would best describe bike index as a
database that allows you to register
your bicycle it's a great way to search
for stolen bikes the way it works for me
is as improving Craigslist I'll notice a
fishy ad and I will immediately open up
bike index and do a quick search for any
bikes that have been stolen in that
geographic area the first time they
recovered a bike I had no idea what I
was doing I drove after work to go meet
this guy and it wasn't one person I was
meeting it was three
and I told them you know guys the cops
are on the way I just called them this
bike was stolen and you're not gonna be
leaving with it eventually through the
bike in the truck burned out returned
the bike and felt great what began as a
simple plan to help a fellow cyclist
took on a life of its own
Seattle's own bike vigilante was born we
were able to recover high 30s or low 40s
of bikes I'm not entirely sure win the
bike vigilante had become a thing it was
probably when the bike Batman moniker
was given to me and this is just
something you know I like doing I don't
need or want you know when your
recognition just doing good is
essentially you know how I try to live
my life and thanks to bike Batman the
cyclists of Emerald City can rest easy
once more
[Music]
haven't you ever had those times in your
life where you just feel all consumed
with tasting something again that you
haven't had in years and years that's
really what I'm doing here is bringing
back those incredible desserts those
incredible experiences that have gone
extinct
I put myself through this process of
resurrecting deserts because I truly
feel that a good desert can change the
course of your day I'm Valerie Gordon
owner of Valerie confections and I'm
also a desert anthropologist the way
this project of resurrecting historic
deserts began was in 2009 the food
editor from the Los Angeles Times
magazine asked me to create a Blum's
coffee crunch cake for an article that
she was doing and it was this amazing
full circle moment because I grew up
with that cake I know that cake and I
missed that cake terribly plums was an
incredible bakery and cafe in California
there were eight locations the last one
closed in the 80s when the article came
out and we literally received 125 phone
calls from people going oh my god
I want this cake the desserts that I
resurrected to date are of course the
coffee crunch cakes and lumps
I've brought back the banana shortcake
from Jason's the Brown Derby grapefruit
cake is another cake that I've
resurrected and now is soon to be the
coffee Estes Sunday as well the
Anthropology of the desert resurrection
is really one of the most interesting
parts of all of this I start the
research process at the Central Library
there is a room and this is a very well
guarded room called the menu vault there
are menus that date back for 150 years
I find that looking at the actual menus
is so much more gratifying than just
pulling something up online because
you're really getting to the heart and
soul of the place
you're almost transported into that
place at that time by holding something
that these people held you really are
now I email a bunch of people or I call
a bunch of people who were natives to
Los Angeles or whatever city the bakery
was in to find out hey do you remember
this do you remember that we always used
to call this the adult Sunday because
this is the one my mom would eat can
they describe the texture of a whipped
cream can they tell me whether there was
vanilla in it or not I'm pretty sure
they did one basic yeah recipe for
whipped cream and then flavored
accordingly and right it was little kid
whipped cream one cherry yes this is
amazing like you have been indispensable
I'm not particularly interested in retro
it is about reliving those sense
memories it's sort of like when you hear
a song that was your favorite song from
1982 you're really thrown back into that
moment it's become this very emotional
very fulfilling part of my job to bring
these cakes back for people
[Music]
in 2010 this man Forrest Fenn hit a
chest filled with gold and rare
artifacts somewhere in the Rocky
Mountains the search for this
million-dollar treasure has obsessed
thousands of seekers worldwide and the
trail starts with this poem which Fenn
wrote it contains nine clues that point
to the treasures location that's here
someplace as I have gone alone in there
and with my treasures Bowl I can keep my
secret ware and hint of riches new and
old fence motivation for hiding the
treasure was to give hope to those
knocked down by the recession and to
inspire them to explore the wild I found
a beautiful little Romanesque treasure
chest and I started filling it up with
with gold coins and gold nuggets and
about two hundred and eighty rubies
there are two salon sapphires there are
eight emeralds a bunch of diamonds but
mostly gold I don't know what it's worth
and I don't even want to think about
that you're not gonna be disappointed if
you find that treasure chest I'm Cynthia
Meacham and I am a full-time treasure
hunter
I have been looking for Finn's treasure
now for a little over three and a half
years
I had two treasure chest more than 8.2
five miles north of Santa Fe in the
Rocky Mountains someplace nobody knows
but me
[Music]
the poem that you have to solve force
always said you have to find where warm
waters halt and to me this is where our
warm waters help that's where I think
that we need to find the treasure chest
[Music]
the thrill of this chase for Fenn's
treasure has led many to leave the
safety of known trails and well beaten
paths the mountains are very unforgiving
it's extremely important that you know
what you're doing and you know where
you're going you can end up in big
trouble really quickly there's even one
hiker that's been lost looking for the
treasure and he hasn't been found yet
[Music]
to fens knowledge the treasure remains a
hidden mystery but the real reward
should come from the hunt
I was positive this was our warm waters
halt and unfortunately I just I don't
think that this is going to be the spot
it doesn't matter what state you
treasure hunt in you're going to have
beautiful scenery like this and it
doesn't matter if you find the treasure
chest or not this is finding the
treasure right here so hear me all and
listen good your effort will be worth
the cold if you are brave and in the
would I give you title to the gold
[Music]
[Music]
the Loch Ness monster is one of our most
enduring myths people have sought its
secrets for over 1500 years but only one
man has devoted his entire life to
learning the truth alone in a van by the
Loch
and no he's not a wacko
it's just his thing my name's Steve
Felton and for the last 25 years I've
been a full-time hunter of the Loch Ness
monster I first came to like this when I
was a seven-year-old boy and found this
set of caravans with this gang of grown
men hunting for monsters in Loch Ness
and I thought that's amazing that would
be the life for me I'd love to do that
and so he did 25 years ago he quit his
job sold his house bought this van and
pursued his passion he now holds the
Guinness record for the longest
continuous search at Loch Ness in all my
time here I've only seen one possible
sighting of something all you saw was a
spray of water off of the back of
something bop bop bop off like a torpedo
going shooting through to this day that
remains a mystery to me as to what that
was that was in the first year of being
here and I thought right this job's
gonna be really easy that's one sighting
25 years later I'm still sat here
waiting for that second sighting some
people think it's giant eels some people
think there's a rip in time others
believe there's a spaceship on the
bottom of the law
it's more likely to turn out to be big
catfish than a spaceship on the bottom
of the law the reason I sit here and I
try and solve this mystery is because
that's what makes my heart sing people
say is it lifestyle or is it the mystery
it's both my life contains freedom
adventure unpredictability and the
chance of one of the world's greatest
discovery should I ever happen to find
Nessie it's a dream come true if that
little seven-year-old boy you could see
what became of him he wouldn't believe
is luck
[Music]